science fiction is now reality 3d
printing has morphed into the mainstream
from consumer use to medical domains the
technology is up ending business with
printers ranging from home use to
industrial scale the technique uses a
digital file to create a 3d object
multiple layers of material usually
plastic are constructed according to the
design from creating hard-to-find parts
to developing model prototypes for the
aviation industry the practice allows
objects to be customized in ways not
previously seen but with the endless
possibilities arise many questions
surrounding regulation if I sell it to
the printer to someone I can't be
responsible of what you making there are
lots of resources online and people can
download a lot of stuff for themself
this is why the parliament is looking at
ways to address intellectual property
and civil liability issues it wants to
create a legal framework for 3d printing
services
[Music]
developing a legal framework would
especially benefit the prosthetics
industry which now has the ability to
tailor make products to meet patient
specific needs any new regulation
shouldn't hamper innovation but rather
take stock of existing rules and future
needs
[Music]